lou holtz is a gridiron legend and a
member of the College Football Hall of
Fame
he is coached in the NFL the SEC and
guided Notre Dame to a national
championship in 1988 Holtz is also
written for or contributed to ten books
but tonight he joins us to discuss
issues at the intersection of sports and
politics have become so prevalent today
coach it's great to see thanks so much
for being here
delighted to be with you Laura
congratulations on the success of your
show thank you so much coach this has
been so wild for me to watch what's
happened in football I mean I've always
been a football fan my whole life my
mother was an Alabama fan sorry coach
she was a wild Alabama fan which I
inherited no particular reason she
disliked Bear Bryant and I just it was
always imbued with a sense of patriotism
and love of country and we're now at a
place where an invitation to the White
House turns a Super Bowl champion coach
into you know a puddle of goo they're
like debating for weeks how to handle it
what has happened in our country well
first of all I was fortunate enough to
take a football team to the White House
and it was one of the great experience
for our players now once again they
weren't going to earn millions of
dollars a year by playing professional
football but I think that we just get
fouled up in what our priorities are the
one thing I always told our team and I
believe is so strongly will not use our
football team to promote anything except
the university or the Philadelphia
Eagles of the New York Jets whatever the
case may be if you want to promote a
cause and use your time and your money
that's fine the locker room belongs to
the players of the NFL they can say
anything they want in there however the
football team on the field belongs to me
and we have to be focused on one thing
we're here to win the Super Bowl nothing
else is bad I don't want any other
distraction this football team except
one focus I congratulate coach Peterson
on just toward a tremendous job he lost
a great quarterback yet he still managed
to win the Super Bowl and I'm very proud
that he was looking forward to getting
to the White House it's unfortunate the
players don't get that experience
and his quarterback was actually one of
the few people who wanted to come to the
White House along with coach Fedderson
Peterson who wanted to come as well but
they didn't make the trip another coach
from the NBA coach Kerr from the Golden
State Warriors made this point coach
about patriotism and Trump let's watch
president is turning all this stuff into
a political game and in a ratings game
and it's a blatant display of
nationalism we just have these military
sing-alongs at the White House to show
how patriotic we are even though we
don't know the words it's just
incredible it is in Chrome but I'm
really proud of people in this country
who are recognizing what's happening and
instead of turning this into a political
game he went on to say there they're
following their conscience basically
that's Steve Kerr of course a coach for
the Warriors
first of all where is he living I think
Golden State is out around San Francisco
and that's probably the view of most
people Laura I'm an individual as I
remember when my father went to the
Pacific for almost five years
I never saw my father for five years but
fortunately he came back many children's
father didn't come back because they
paid the ultimate sacrifice I've been to
Afghanistan last June I was in Korea the
DMZ so to go into a hospital in
Afghanistan to see people have lost
their legs etc and yet they still have a
love of this country when you talk about
politics then that is what's coming into
this game if you don't believe in
something and I think it comes back down
saying that President Trump's a racist I
get tired of hearing a racist homophobia
settle for 70 some years he did business
he was in the fund recliner there was
never claimed one time about him being a
racist I was in Detroit yesterday Ben
Carson we're trying to do some things
for the disadvantaged youth under
president Trump's leadership they had a
sign error and I thought it was great
it said talents equally distributed
around the world opportunities not miss
work to give people an opportunity
particularly the young people but I've
learned been more cop shot this year
than in the previous year you just keep
looking at it it's absolutely insane
because we daren't focus we have a
problem because
different subjective when might have a
difference of opinion how to make
America great how to get people off dude
how to win a champion coach curves done
a tremendous job he has some great
athletes he also won several
championships when he was a player
congratulations on that but when you
talk about a political statement read
Steve Kerr's comment that says it all
well I think what they're saying is the
players are following their conscience
about police brutality it's not about
the country it's not about the flag
they're very patriotic people but they
are just in their own way protesting
against police brutality and they think
Trump doesn't understand that so they
don't want to go spend time with Trump I
think what President Trump said this
morning's race he said to all the
players you talk about Bruce Burke town
you talk about police being unfair bring
it to me bring me the case bring me the
people I will look into it that it can't
do any more than that but let's not use
sports in order to promote a cause we're
there to win a championship that's our
only purpose I can tell you coach I was
at the White House when the Crimson Tide
came of course national champions this
year they all came coach you know I
think made it clear everybody's coming
I'm sure players didn't like Trump there
but they came they had a great time it
was a beautiful event it was packed out
and to me that's what it's all about we
put aside politics it's about the
country and that's the people's house
and celebrating national champions
Lou Lou it's so great to see you a huge
fan and come back soon would you I will
but we got to go to Notre Dame to a game
like you requested okay we're doing that
this fall okay you and I are going to a
game this fall I have I'm embarrassed
I've never been to Notre Dame
I am completely embarrassed so I am
coming this fall with you that is a date
coach thanks so much thank you